bonjour avoue stéphanie gibeau merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france dix ans jour pour jour que
wikileaks a publié près de 400 mille
documents secrets sur la guerre en irak
à l'époque comment cette révélation a
été perçue aux états unis mais aussi
partout ailleurs dans le monde pour les
américains c'est clair que ça a été un
choc qui ne les a pas laissés sans voix
puisqu'ils ont essayé de répondre
justement en discréditant wikileaks et
en discréditant à 100 sheila étant
wikileaks ne s'en est pas laissé compter
et a continué après donc ces révélations
sur la guerre en irak en afghanistan
après le traitement des prisonniers à
guantanamo après les lic ce qui concerne
le comité national démocrate ce qui
s'appelle et clinton l'x les mails de
pau destin après avoir appris que les
présidents chirac sarkozy et hollande
avait été écouté par la haine et c'est
après les révélations d'évasion fiscale
de la banque julius baer points ça
n'arrête pas tous les pays d'ailleurs en
pas que les américains aient aussi des
knicks sur la syrie sur la russie et
puis la révolte seven qui concerne les
contrôles des smartphones par l'acier
mais comment les états unis ont répondu
à tous un mic pompéo en 2017 disait que
wikileaks était un service de
renseignement hostile alors que façon
justement des zecs wikileaks était un
service de renseignement des citoyens
alors justement qu'est ce que wikileaks
a changé dans les secrets d'état les
révélations médiatiques
ce qu'on sait tous les uns les autres
c'est qu'en fait
assange et wikileaks on fournit des
informations des documents qui était
vrai qu'ils avaient été vérifiées et
dont la véracité ne peut pas être remise
en cause c'est à dire que ce sont des
informations d'intérêt général pour vous
qui êtes journaliste vous connaissez
forcément la charte de munich c'est à
dire que tous les principes de la charte
de munich ont été respectées
et ce qui est très surprenant ce qui est
même très choquant c'est justement la
responsabilité de tous les journalistes
de tous les médias mainstream sans
compter tous les hommes politiques
qu'ils soient américains français et
européens ou qui vous voulez sur la
planète de ne pas être allé soutenir du
les massages c'est à dire de ne pas
soutenir un journalisme qui est à la
fois un journalisme d'investigation et
un journalisme qui dit la vérité
pourquoi parce que ce procès qui a lieu
en grande bretagne concernant à 100 je
n'ai qu'un procès politique
je crois que la semaine dernière en
allemagne dont l'une a songé reçu le 47e
prix en tant que journaliste c'est donc
lui qui est en prison alors qu'il n'y a
aucune conséquence pour ceux qui ont
commis des crimes de sang
pour ceux qui sont impliqués dans des
affaires de corruption ou dans des
scandales
incroyable ce qui change depuis dix ans
et qu'aujourd'hui les citoyens
commencent en avoir un petit peu marre
et ils se rendent compte les uns les
autres qui est un mensonge orchestré
notamment depuis ce qu'on peut appeler
cette crise que vit de 19 depuis le
début de l'année c'est à dire qu'il ya
des rétro pédalage dans tous les sens je
ne sais pas si vous avez entendu là les
déclarations une autre ancien premier
ministre qui parlait de du port du
masque en disant qu'il n'y avait aucun
que ce sens rien rien de porter des
masques et qui en fait qui dit penser
comme ça c'était la doctrine c'est à
dire que nos hommes politiques n'ont ni
éthique ni morale et on le voit sur le
dossier julian assange
malheureusement alors justement pour
conclure stéphanie et gibeau juliana
sont donc qui risque d'être extradé aux
etats-unis les risques 175 ans de prison
le procès doit s'achever en janvier
prochain
ce que les jeux sont déjà faits selon
vous est-ce qu'il peut y avoir
justement une liste jeu favorable pour
julian assange
moi je pense si vous voulez qu'avec ce
contexte c'est à la société française de
se mobiliser pour du lait n'a sens pour
la france pour la défense de nos valeurs
de se mobiliser pour la vérité pourquoi
parce qu'on a été capable en france
d'accueillir des dictateurs monsieur dû
gagner pendant 25 ans pourquoi ce
dictateur a eu le droit d'asile et du
loup menaçant je ne l'aurais pas il ya
toujours deux poids deux mesures donc
les français qui commence en avoir un
petit peu marre de tous ces mensonges
politiques qu'ils comprennent que
personne ne leur a apporté plus de lits
dans des hôpitaux plus de moyens pour
les policiers plus de considération et
plus de professions de protection pardon
pour les professeurs vont se mobiliser
je pense parce que il ya un grand danger
justement sur la vérité est que
malheureusement tous ces mensonges en
france ça ne fait que affaiblir
géopolitiquement notre pays
alors justement vous dites que les
lignes bougent au sein de l'opinion
publique et au sein de des pouvoirs
politiques qu en est il selon mais je
pense et ça c'est à dire qu'en fait
aujourd'hui les gens commencent à se
rendre compte que nos hommes politiques
n'ont aucune crédibilité
alors à partir du moment où les gens
peuvent-ils avoir la légitimité vous
parlais à l'instant des déclarations de
dieu notre ancien premier ministre ce
fip
mais c'est tellement choquant si vous
voulez de voir quand même que ce genre à
son pays avec les impôts tous les
français qu'on me demande de payer de
plus en plus d'impôts et j'en sais
quelque chose pour avoir travaillé sur
ce dossier ubs et de voir finalement
comment les temps à traiter mon propre
dossier
donc si vous voulez la corruption
française qui est en train de détruire
notre pays petit à petit qu'il est en
train de détruire aussi les français
puisque on voit bien qu'avec cette
mauvaise gestion de la crise comme il ya
plus de chômeurs est plus de précarité y
avoir de plus en plus de violence
sociale
c'est un politique qui se pensent
intouchable il devrait peut-être penser
à ce qui est arrivé à monsieur cahuzac
qui disait
dans l'assemblée nationale ni de près ni
de loin ses inconstances offshore donc
en suisse et en plus chez ubs
donc qu'ils se méfient ils vont être en
danger s'ils continuent de mentir
mais exactement comme les médias
mainstream qui ne font pas leur métier
d'aller voir la vérité et à ce titre je
vous remercie de m'inviter
puisque vous êtes les seuls à le faire
et à parler de ce livre la traque des
lanceurs dallaire préfacé par du l'une
assange qui me vaut depuis quatre ans
d'être complètement ostracisé voire
censurer par tous les médias français
merci beaucoup à vous en tout cas je la
stéphanie gibeau d'avoir été avec nous
en direct
merci de vous exprimer librement son rt
franc je rappelle vous être l'auteur de
l'ouvragé la traque des lanceurs d'alert
préfacé par julian assange ans